امتلاك كلا الأمرين يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا
بالطبع
لفريق جودة ريال مدريد ولكن
الباب مفتوح لنا
للجميع لفتحه بشكل أكبر
الأسبوع المقبل أو لا أعتقد أن هذا هو
تفكيري الفوري ، أعتقد أن هناك
مشاعر مختلطة حول  المباراة
أعتقد أنها كانت كبيرة لفترة 11
رجلاً ،
كنا في اللعبة ولدينا بعض
الفرص وأعتقد أنه يمكننا تقديم أفضل وأعتقد أنني
كنت هنا لفترة قصيرة
وهناك بالتأكيد أشياء أعتقد  أنه
يمكننا الاستفادة من قوتنا بشكل أفضل
خاصة مع نظام الظهير الأجنحة ،
فقد يكون الأمر أكثر
إلحاحًا نظرًا لوجود مشكلة في ذلك ،
لذا فهذه أشياء يجب أن
أعمل عليها أنا والموظفين واللاعبين
لأنني أستطيع ذلك لأنني استطعت أن أرى
الفرصة  هناك الليلة بطرق لذلك
لم نأخذ
روح نهاية اللعبة
العشرة رجال العظماء هنا لمدة نصف ساعة كما
تعلمون أن الكثير من الأشياء يمكن أن
تحدث ولا أعتقد أننا قدمنا ​​لهم
الكثير  الكثير من الفرص الرائعة ،
لذلك أحب هذا الجزء منها وعلينا
أن نعتقد أنني بحاجة إلى أن أكون أول
من يؤمن بأن هذا ممكن